it's hard just today I got a bad review
of my book in the New York Times the day
it comes out I'm in New York the goddamn
New York Times gives me a terrible
review it hurts there's no secret to it
I imagine Shakespeare hated getting
negative reviews and you know there's
always going to be someone who doesn't
like what you do always no matter you
know Tolstoy Shakespeare Dante I'm sure
they're people who told them their stuff
sucks it hurts you know you give
everything to arch I said we are a story
animals so when your story is rejected
it's it hits you right here you know if
you're a dentist's if you're an
accountant you can have bad days at work
it's just your job it's not who you are
art just like religion it's who we are
so when you get a bad review it's your
entire being that is negated and that
hurts not that you do for approval
you're not pandering for approval you
don't do it for approval you have to let
go but in people that you care for you
know you know you want you know you want
to impress the people close to you you
know you don't want to written a novel
within your your your wife your
girlfriend your boyfriend your parents
would f does then sort of have to sort
of you know lie you don't you know so
your art is profoundly social so you
want it some level your gift to be
accepted I say that but at the same time
it is a free gift you have to let go you
have to have that Buddhist attitude of
passionate detachment which I generally
had I might just got that review today
so that kind of sucks but you have to
let go